[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend ihnen allen
schönen dass sie dabei sind wie auch
Norbert Lehmann voller Feuer Vorfreude
auf das Fußballspieler
russland will Fakten schaffen
scheinreferenten in besetzten Gebieten
im Süden und Osten der Ukraine starten
Abstimmungen über den Beitritt zu
Russland
Milliardenloch bei den Krankenkassen
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
will viele an den Kosten beteiligen auch
Versicherte sollen mehr zahlen
und Flagge zeigen für mehr Klimaschutz
beim globalen klimastreik gehen allein
in Deutschland zehntausende Fridays for
future Aktivisten auf die Straße
[Musik]
willkommen zu hause so inszeniert
Russland heute die scheinabstimmungen in
den besetzten Gebieten in der Ukraine
von einer echten Abstimmung kann keine
Rede sein es geht darum die Gebiete
Russland einzuferleiben bei jedem
ukrainischen
rückeroberungsversuch könnte Moskau dann
zum Beispiel behaupten auf eigenem
Territorium attackiert worden zu sein
in vier Regionen wird abgestimmt in den
Separatisten Gebieten Don jetzt und
johannsk in der Ostukraine und im Süden
in den von Russland kontrollierten
Teilen der Regionen chasson und
saporicia die sogenannten Referenten
sollen bis Dienstag laufen weder die
Ukraine noch die internationale
Gemeinschaft erkennen Sie an Sebastian
ihm berichtet
in den russischen Staatsmedien gibt es
heute nur ein Thema der Beginn der
sogenannten Volksabstimmungen in den
besetzten Gebieten eine Reporterin zeigt
den Andrang vor einem mobilen Wahllokal
auf einem Fabrikgelände in der Region
saporicia aus Angst vor ukrainischen
Angriffen sollen feste Wahllokale erst
am Dienstag öffnen heißt es die die im
Staatsfernsehen zu Wort kommen äußern
sich eindeutig
alle waren einverstanden heute hierher
zu kommen wir haben darauf gewartet wir
wollen Frieden und das Gute
ich liebe Russland
3,5 Millionen Menschen sind aufgerufen
ihre Stimme abzugeben auch im immer noch
weitestgehend zerstörten mariopol haben
sie behelfsmäßige wahlstationen
aufgebaut die Anführer der Separatisten
lassen sich gerne bei der Abstimmung
Filmen und inszenieren sich dabei als
faire Demokraten so wie hier Dennis
puschilin der vom Kreml eingesetzte
Anführer der selbst ernannten
Volksrepublik dorniezk für Experten in
Deutschland ist die Abstimmung eine
Farce sie versuchen damit vier
ukrainische Gebiete die Sie gerade zum
Teil besetzt halten in russisches
Territorium zu überführen russland will
damit Druck auf uns ausüben auf den
Westen und auf die Ukraine
um uns im Handeln einzuschränken also
sagen haltet euch raus
in Moskau selbst läuft die
Propagandamaschinerie des Kreml an zur
Unterstützung der Abstimmungen finden
heute hier genau wie in vielen anderen
Städten Veranstaltungen statt das Motto
wir lassen euch nicht im Stich am Tag 1
der sogenannten Volksabstimmungen
zweifelt hier kaum jemand daran dass das
Ergebnis in fünf Tagen deutlich
ausfallen wird
fragen wir Christian sem in Moskau
vorgestern wurden die Proteste gegen die
teilmobilisierung brutal
niedergeschlagen heute werden die
Referenten gefeiert welche Atmosphäre
herrscht im Land
ja das war heute ein Tag der ganz im
Zeichen des Patriotismus stand im ganzen
Land gab es diese Veranstaltung diese
organisierten Konzerte und Kundgebungen
zur Solidarität für diese Referenten da
sind verschiedene Redner aufgetreten die
noch mal richtig eingeheizt haben und
die im Prinzip noch mal die Propaganda
wiederholt haben die wir hier immer
wieder am Staatsfernsehen hören vor
allem mit dem Kernpunkt dass diese
Gebiete befreit werden mussten von den
Neonazis also diesen Grund hört man ja
immer wieder und der wird immer und
immer wiederholt Putin braucht diese
Bilder um zu versuchen das Volk hinter
sich zu vereinen und auch um noch mal
Werbung für diese doch sehr umstrittene
Mobilisierung zu machen ist denn
mittlerweile klarer wen diese
Mobilisierung trifft wer da eingezogen
wird
das ist der unterschiedlich manche haben
die Befehl schon zugestellt bekommen den
den Bescheid und müssen jetzt antreten
andere Rätseln tatsächlich immer noch ob
Sie betroffen sein könnten weil ihr
Status nicht ganz klar ist das führt
dann dazu dass doch noch einige
versuchen das Land zu verlassen und eine
der wenig begehrten Flugverbindungen zu
kriegen in Ländern die Russen noch
reisen können und Russen die sich
derzeit noch im Ausland befinden
vielleicht im Urlaub und auch nicht
genau wissen ob sie dazu gehören die
überlegen sich jetzt im Moment sehr
genau ob sie in die Heimat zurückkehren
danke schön nach Moskau Christian sem
der ukrainische Präsident selenski hat
sich direkt an die russische Bevölkerung
gewandt und zum Widerstand gegen die
teilmobilisierung aufgerufen
55.000 russische Soldaten sein bereits
gestorben so selensky wer nicht noch
mehr Tote wolle solle sich wehren
protestieren weglaufen oder sich ergeben
und wie reagieren die Menschen in der
Ukraine auf die scheinreferenten unsere
reporter-torge Bode hat sich in der
Gegend rund um die Kleinstadt baschtanka
umgehört das liegt im Süden des Landes
nahe der Region charson die schon bald
von Russland annektiert werden könnte
es ist noch einmal deutlich mehr Militär
unterwegs seit einigen Tagen die Straße
nachbarstanka nur wenige Kilometer von
der südlichen Frontlinie entfernt im
März kämpften auf den Straßen von
bastanka Ukrainer gegen Russen das jetzt
eine neue russische Grenze durch eine
scheinabstimmung noch näher an ihre
Stadt heranrücken könnte daran will hier
niemand glauben
diese Abstimmung gibt es doch nur weil
das was Putin geplant hat nicht klappt
ich finde dass unsere Soldaten und
unsere Regierung die Russen wieder
hinter die Grenze jagen sollten
man braucht keine Referendum wozu soll
das gut sein
das bedeutet das Putin unser Land
erobern will er will dass wir Russen
werden aber das gelingt ihm nicht
Kampfflugzeuge am Himmel Anspannung
liegt in der Luft wenn Russland die
besetzten Gebiete wie erwartet ins
eigene Land eingliedern würde würden ab
dem Moment Ukraine auf russisches
Staatsgebiet feuern und auf russische
Staatsbürger für offizierte Linsky wird
sich dadurch nichts ändern
jeder der eine Waffe in die Hand nimmt
und gegen uns kämpft ist der Feind der
keinen Krieg mit uns will sollte keine
Waffe in die Hand nehmen
mit dem heutigen Beginn der
scheinreferenten setzt Russland aus
Sicht der Ukraine weiter auf Eskalation
wie umgehen mit russischen Kriegsdienst
Verweigerern die sich nach der
Teilmobilmachung ins Ausland retten
wollen die EU will am Montag über eine
gemeinsame Linie beraten die
Bundesregierung hat angekündigt
großzügig Schutz zu gewähren allerdings
müsse darauf geachtet werden ob
ausreisende womöglich im Auftrag der
russischen Staatsmacht kämen sagt
Regierungssprecher Hebestreit
Corona ist noch nicht vorbei doch die
finanziellen Folgen spüren die
gesetzlichen Krankenkassen längst ihnen
fehlen 17 Milliarden Euro ein
Rekorddefizit das sollen jetzt unter
anderem die Versicherten Auffangen der
Gesundheitsminister will den
Zusatzbeitrag um 0,3 Prozentpunkte
erhöhen die Hälfte sollen die
Versicherten zahlen die andere Hälfte
die Arbeitgeber insgesamt läge der
Krankenkassenbeitrag dann bei
16,2%. im Bundestag gab es heute viel
Kritik für die Pläne Britta Spiekermann
Karl Lauterbach geht von Baustelle zu
Baustelle erst das
Infektionsschutzgesetz nur mit Ach und
Krach über die Bühne gebracht jetzt wie
er sagt ein geerbtes Rekorddefizit der
Krankenkassen Milliarden Löcher müssen
gestoppt werden und trotzdem der
Minister gibt ein Versprechen wir wollen
keine Leistungskürzungen
Leistungskürzungen in einer Zeit wo die
Menschen bedroht sind durch Krieg
Inflation steigende Energiepreise
möglicherweise Rezession das ist eine
Situation wo Kürzungen der
Gesundheitsversorgung nicht vermittelbar
sind daran wird der Minister in Zukunft
gemessen werden geplant ist den
Zusatzbeitrag der Krankenkassen um 0,3
Prozentpunkte anzuheben den sich
Arbeitgeber und versicherte Teilen auf
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher könnten
zum Jahreswechsel höhere Kosten zukommen
ein Beispiel wer 3.500 Euro brutto
verdient müsste rund 5 Euro im Monat und
60 Euro im Jahr mehr zahlen
um das Gesundheitssystem stabil zu
halten braucht es so die Regierung
weitere milliardenzuschüsse des Bundes
Rücklagen der Krankenkassen werden wie
es heißt abgeschmolzen auch Apotheken
und Pharmaindustrie sollen ihren Anteil
leisten dem Gesetz fehlten strukturelle
Reformen kritisiert Bayerns
Gesundheitsminister
sie steuern auf einen Kassen Crash zu
auf einem Blick
ackout weitermachen und da nützt es
nichts wenn Sie ankündigen wir werden
dann was vorlegen jetzt müssen sie
vorlegen steigende Energiepreise und
Inflation Kliniken haben bereits
erhöhten Finanzbedarf angemeldet der
Bund will per extra Gesetz zügig
nachlegen das Gesundheitssystem soll
2023 abgesichert werden mehr ist es
erstmal nicht es geht an die Reserven
und somit wir mehr Informationen rund um
die geplante Erhöhung der Kassenbeiträge
finden Sie online und in der ZDF heute
App dort haben wir die wichtigsten
Fragen und Antworten für Sie
zusammengestellt
egal wo auf der weltfrauen müssen
selbstbestimmt leben können ohne um ihr
Leben zu fürchten das twitterte heute
der Bundeskanzler als Reaktion auf den
Tod einer jungen Frau in Iran sie war
von der Sittenpolizei festgenommen
worden weil ihr Kopftuch angeblich nicht
richtig saß seit einer Woche gibt es in
Iran deswegen heftige regimekritische
Proteste mindestens 26 26 Menschen
starben heute rief die Regierung zu
Gegendemos auf Kristina grüntgen
berichtet
es sind diese Bilder die das iranische
Regime der Welt gerne zeigt tausende
Menschen auf den Straßen von Teheran in
Solidarität mit der Regierung
ich glaube aus tiefstem Herzen das nach
unserer Scharia der Hijab bleiben sollte
wir brauchen eine ausführliche
Diskussion über den hijob es ist falsch
dass nur die Sittenpolizei regeln zu
lassen aber Frauen sollten wissen dass
dies ein islamisches Land ist jeder der
hier leben will sollte sich an die
Regeln halten vor allem nachts zeigt
sich seit Tagen ein anderes Bild
brennende Polizeiwagen Frauen die ihre
Kopftücher abnehmen und hartes
Durchgreifen der Sicherheitskräfte
mindestens 26 Tote meldet das
Staatsfernsehen wie viele es wirklich
sind lässt sich kaum überprüfen das
Internet ist weitgehend blockiert
mehrere Journalisten wurden festgenommen
beim Freitagsgebet in Teheran ruft
gebetsführer katami die Justiz auf
entschieden gegen die Anführer der
Proteste vorzugehen
hier geht es nicht um das Mädchen hier
geht es darum unsere Religion
anzugreifen den Koran zu verbrennen und
den muslimischen Frauen das Kopftuch
abzunehmen
Präsident reisi meinte die Menschen
dürften friedlich demonstrieren doch
Chaos werde nicht toleriert die
Sicherheitskräfte riefen dazu auf sich
nicht mehr an den Protesten zu
beteiligen das kann bedeuten dass man
jetzt noch härter gegen die
Demonstrationen vorgehen will doch viele
werden wohl trotz der Drohungen weiter
demonstrieren auch heute Abend
beim Untergang eines flüchtlingsboots
vor der Küste Syriens sind mindestens 70
Menschen ums Leben gekommen und 20
konnten bislang gerettet werden sie
werden in der syrischen Hafenstadt
Tartus medizinisch versorgt das Boot
soll nach offiziellen Angaben mit über
100 Flüchtenden im Libanon gestartet
sein immer wieder wagen Migranten die
gefährliche Fahrt über das Mittelmeer
nach Europa
Krieg explodierende Energiekosten
drohende Wirtschaftskrise heute wollte
Fridays for future mit einem globalen
klimastreik zeigen wir sind auch noch da
auf allen Kontinenten beteiligten sich
vor allem Jugendliche an den Protesten
für mehr Klimaschutz in Japan zum
Beispiel oder in Neu-Delhi in Indien
auch in vielen europäischen Städten wie
hier in Turin gingen Tausende auf die
Straßen über die Forderungen der Jungen
klimaschütze in Berlin berichtet
Stefanie gargosch
Fridays for future rief zum 11 globalen
klimaprotest über 30.000 kam allein in
Berlin unter dem Motto Menschen statt
Profite demonstrierten die Generationen
gemeinsam
der Welt geht sehr schlecht wenn so
weitergeht wir müssen was tun und vieles
lassen Umdenken einfach Maßnahmen dass
wir die 1,5 Grad Grenze einhalten damit
wir im Grunde genommen für die nächsten
Generationen auch
ein lebenswerten Planeten hinterlassen
bei der Kundgebung dabei auch das
bekannteste Gesicht von Fridays for
future in Deutschland Luisa Neubauer
Forderungen
die Klimakrise ist kein Unfall das ist
kein Zufall die Klimakrise ist eine
politische Entscheidung wir fordern 100
Milliarden für Klimaschutz und
Sicherheit das wird nicht reichen aber
was ist ein Anfang
trotz weniger Präsenz während
corona-ukraine und Energiekrise sichert
sich Fridays for future eine
langanhaltende Stimme heute allein in
270 deutschen Städten das ist eine
Bewegung die wie viele andere soziale
Bewegungen immer wieder Präsenz zeigt
immer wieder ihr Thema auf die auf die
Agenda setzt und damit letztlich über
die Langfristigkeit ihres Engagements
und auch des Protestes immer wieder auch
dafür sorgt dass politisch darüber aus
einer anderen Perspektive gesprochen
wird auch die Energiekrise sei eine
Folge der Klimakrise riefen sie der
Politik heute entgegen auf der ganzen
Welt
die
Energiekrise trifft auch Produkte bei
denen man es auf Anhieb nicht vermuten
würde Bier zum Beispiel um Bier in die
Flasche zu bekommen braucht es nämlich
Kohlensäure und Kohlensäure ist derzeit
Mangelware warum und was das für Folgen
hat zeigt Julian Schmidt ferend
20.000 Flaschen pro Stunde Bier Limo
Wasser seit mehr als 120 Jahren ist die
Augsburger Brauerei Riegele fest in der
Hand der Familie von Sebastian Priller
nun wird der Produktionsstopp der
Braubranche geht die Kohlensäure aus
wann der Nachschub kommt unklar Kollegen
stehen mittlerweile weil sie keine
Kohlensäure mehr haben das heißt Sie
können nicht mehr abfüllen komplett
andere können einzelne Produkte nicht
mehr abfüllen das Problem der Brauereien
die düngemittelproduktion stoppt die
Gaspreise machen das Geschäft unrentabel
und das günstige Abfallprodukt ist
Kohlensäure fällt weg
vor allem die kleine mittelständischen
Brauereien trifft es weil ab einer
bestimmten Hektoliter Zahl kann man
seine eigene Kohlensäure gewinnen beim
Gärprozess das macht aber eben erst Sinn
ab einer gewissen Größe allein in Bayern
leiden mehr als 100 Betriebe unter der
Situation so der Verband der Privaten
Brauereien die Brauereien Augsburg kann
wahrscheinlich mit Krediten die
Durststrecke überleben anderen tut jetzt
die Insolvenz wenn es keine Kohlensäure
am Markt gibt ja dann werden natürlich
die großen dein Großkunden beliefen
werden als erstes mit Kohlensäure
beliefert ja und irgendwann in der
Nahrungskette kommt dann wir mit
Kohlensäure und die die kleiner sind als
wir vielleicht die bekommen dann gar
keine Kohlensäure mehr die Kohlensäure
vielleicht nur der Anfang die Zulieferer
ächzen unter den Energiekosten und
Sebastian prillers sorgen Liste wird
immer länger
tja kommen wir zur Fußball nations
League Norbert in eineinhalb Stunden ist
Anpfiff Deutschland gegen Ungarn ja und
da hofft das Team von Hansi flickt
natürlich das ist nach dem Apfelfest
Sieg für die DFB-Elf drei Punkte heute
ja und der Gruppensieg ist zum
greifender Jochen Breyer in Leipzig
trotz des Heimvorteils die Ungarn sind
ja bekanntlich doch schwer zu knacken
oh ja das kann man so sagen wir erinnern
uns an die Fußball-Europameisterschaft
letztes Jahr der hat die deutsche
Mannschaft mit Ach und Krach ein zwei zu
zwei erreicht und beim letzten Treffen
im Juni in der nations League auch nur
ein eins zu eins gerade so durch den
späten Ausgleich von Jonas Hofmann also
Ungarn ist nicht umsonst Tabellenführer
aber es geht heute nicht nur um Platz 1
in dieser Gruppe sondern vor allem
natürlich um sich für die
Weltmeisterschaft in Katar einzuspielen
und ein bisschen warm zu spielen das
hier heute Abend ist nur einer von zwei
Stresstests auf dem Weg zur
Weltmeisterschaft für das Team von Hansi
Flick und die große Frage ist ist das
Team schon in WM-Form ja oder nein wir
melden uns um 20 Uhr hier aus Leipzig
danke Jochen bis später
Deutschland mit guten Chancen auf das
Finalturnier Weltmeister Frankreich
dagegen kämpft gegen den Abstieg aus der
A-Liga und holt einen wichtigen Sieg und
zwar gestern Abend gegen Österreich
Kilian mbappé schießt sein Team in der
56 minute in Führung ja und 9 Minuten
später sorgt Olivier girou für den 2:0
entstand
und bei der Ruder-WM in Tschechien hat
der deutsche Achter erneut enttäuscht
nach dem vierten Platz im Vorlauf blieb
das DRV Paradeboot auch im Hoffnungslauf
chancenlos und verpasste damit das
Finale
wie im Vorlauf so sind die ersten 500
Meter noch konkurrenzfähig beim
einstigen deutschen Flaggschiff danach
verliert der achterschlag Umschlag das
stark verjüngte Team um Tauben
johannesen zu dem corona-geschwächt auf
Rang 3 im Hoffnungslauf kein Finale zum
ersten Mal seit 23 Jahren das muss es
einfach noch nicht so ja so wie
Zahnräder zusammen funktioniert sondern
dass da noch ein kleiner Bruch drin ist
Weltmeister Oliver Zeidler dagegen hat
seine Favoritenrolle herausragend
ausgefüllt der Titelverteidiger im einer
mit einem überlegenen Sieg in seinem
Halbfinale muss mich jetzt ausruhen fürs
Finale und dann hoffen dass der letzte
Schlag im Finale der letzte ist den ich
machen kann und dann kann da alles
passieren
auch der Doppel zweier der Frauen
schafft es in den Endlauf mit der
Hoffnung auf eine Medaille in den
olympischen Klassen
ja trotz dieser Folge bislang keine gute
WM für den Deutschen Ruderverband schade
wir drücken die Daumen ist ja noch ein
bisschen was ne ja heute ist
Herbstbeginn und damit geht auch das
ruhige Wetter zu Ende morgen wird es
nass die Details hat gleich aus den
terli das heute journal mit Marietta
Slomka in der Halbzeitpause um 21 Uhr
die gesamte heute Redaktion wünscht
Ihnen ein schönes Wochenende und bedankt
sich für ihr Interesse bis morgen wenn
sie mal auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter pünktlich zum
heutigen Herbstbeginn ändert sich auch
das Wetter von Westen her kommt Regen
auf schuld daran ist dieses T4 man sieht
hier von Südwesten kommen Wolken und
Regen ins Land es wird also auch nicht
ganz so kühl werden wir schauen mal auf
die Nacht unter regnet es im Westen bis
nach Schleswig-Holstein hoch und
Richtung Oberrhein sonst ist es zunächst
trocken Richtung Donau bildet sich
erneut Nebel die Temperaturen gehen
zurück auf vier bis sechs Grad im
Südosten Deutschlands aber die Nacht ist
nicht ganz so kalt wie die vorherige
zwölf im Westen und 13 Richtung
Oberrhein ja morgen dann viele shower im
Westen Richtung norddeutsche Tiefebene
und Schleswig-Holstein recht ungemütlich
und am Nachmittag gibt es im Südwesten
Gewitter ja und in der Mitte auch
Sonnenschein sowie nach Osten hin
Temperaturen dazu Maximalwerte bis 20
Grad Entwicklung Sachsen etwa und 14
Grad am Alpenrand kommenden Tage bringen
weitere shower mit vor allem am Sonntag
sind auch Gewitter dabei im Osten ist es
aber trocken bei 14 bis 19 Grad danach
wird es etwas kühler und es bleibt
unbeständig einen schönen Abend